90 of bitcoin has already been mined yes
most people already know that there are
only ever going to be 21 million bitcoin
that is the total supply but the mining
process allows for more and more bitcoin
of that 21 million to come into the
circulating supply it started out that
approximately every 10 minutes 50
bitcoin were mined and put into the
circulating supply that continued for
four years eventually we got the having
went from 50 to 25 bitcoin every 10
minutes we then went from 25 bitcoin
every 10 minutes for four years down to
12 and a half that continued for four
years and then we got the last halving
which took us from 12 and a half to 6.25
bitcoin every 10 minutes it's about 900
bitcoin per day coming into the
circulating supply but now we have
achieved in the first 12 years or so 90
of all bitcoin are now mined and in
circulation miners currently receive
that 6.25 bitcoin each block that they
mine and after the next having it'll
drop to 3.125 bitcoin
every time they mine a block mining will
continue the mining process will
continue until
2140 the year 2140 as you can see here
this is the total circulating bitcoin
and as you can see it is only going to
continue to increase all the way until
we get to 21 million total bitcoin if
you then go ahead and you look at this
other chart we have with the total
circulating bitcoin you can see as well
it's just open to the right that's how
we do it we're just going to keep going
till we get to 21 million so how many
bitcoin are there well you can see here
that there are 18 million 978
781 bitcoin that are in existence
already that means that there are just
over two million bitcoin that are left
to be mined that's 90 of bitcoin already
issued or mined and there's 900 new
bitcoin coming into the market each and
every day and so when you start to think
about this obviously bitcoin is just a
supply and demand equation the supply is
fixed the total supply and the incoming
supply is programmatic that's supply
schedule 900 bitcoin per day we know it
we can prove it we know exactly what's
going to happen tomorrow as well and
when it happens we can prove it then as
well but the demand is the thing that
everyone continues to try to model and
so you're trying to understand do more
or less people want bitcoin than they
did one year ago five years ago 10 years
ago and what we have seen is demand has
continued to increase but it may not be
just that simple that there will only
ever be 21 million bitcoin in
circulation once all of them have been
mined according to chain analysis
there's about 3.7 million bitcoin that
they estimate have been lost based on
analyzing address activity now this
isn't a precise number because it's hard
to actually understand how many bitcoin
have been lost sometimes you just have
somebody who got a bunch of bitcoin they
held it for 10 years and you think it
was lost but then all of a sudden the
coin moves and you say oh somebody still
must have control or access to that
wallet or that address and so this is an
estimation it's about 3.7 million they
estimate have been lost a further 1
million bitcoin are suspected to be held
by satoshi nakamoto and it's untouched
which is part of the beauty of bitcoin
is that the creator had the
genius to create bitcoin but was humble
enough to walk away now could those
coins move at some point in the future
sure but it's unlikely and even if they
did nothing would necessarily change
about the network people would just
begin speculating about who satoshi is
and where they are why did they come
back and what does that mean but
ultimately it would be no different than
other dormant coins moving after a very
long time and so these numbers are
heavily debated is it really one million
coins held by satoshi is it eight
hundred thousand is it somewhere in
between or is it a different number
nobody actually knows we can simply look
at the on-chain metrics and do our best
to try to guess what that is so between
lost coins and what satoshi holds it is
not fully understood but we do have some
estimates now if we go ahead and we look
at the bitcoin circulating supply as a
percent of the 21 million total bitcoin
you can see here that 90 of that total
supply has now been issued or mined and
that gives us an inflation rate of about
1.88
the beauty is that the bitcoin inflation
rate is closer to the fed's two percent
target than the fed has been all year so
bitcoin doing a great job to actually
obtain
somewhere that is much much lower than
the central banks that have variable
monetary policies and then lastly if we
go ahead and we look at those halvings
what you can see here is the lines that
are drawn vertically you can see those
are the actual having moments but the
price itself continues to increase
significantly post-having and when you
see that what you can tell is that
regardless of what people say the having
has never been priced in before
you usually hear people argue that the
having in bitcoin is priced in and what
they are saying is that it is a market
efficient argument everyone has the same
information everyone knows when the
having is coming and therefore it gets
priced in unfortunately that completely
ignores the fact that everyone in the
market doesn't know about the havoc they
can't even describe how it works they
don't know when it's going to happen
and the people who show up post-having
have no clue that it already occurred
and so naturally what we get is we get
21 million total bitcoin in the supply
we've got 90 of them that have already
been mined or issued now and this is
likely just to continue bitcoin does not
care what's going on in politics in any
sort of geopolitical disagreement they
do not care what's going on with public
health crisis simply produces block
after block after block of transactions
it is a programmatic transparent
monetary policy it's the most
disciplined central bank in the world
and it continues to just do exactly what
it was built to do to be robust
to be resilient and to continue to
protect our purchasing power